it's interesting where we can go through
these periods of feeling like we're fine
and we don't have any issues but
actually deep within us there are these
traumas that are just waiting to come
out some other point in life all right
so this episode is all about burnout the
society that we live in the over
stimulation that we get from the phones
and from social media and from our work
and this constant desire to be
constantly on and never really switching
off and so today's guest is very fun
because his name is Hector Hughes and he
basically specializes in helping people
do digital detoxes he had his own
experience of burnout and now he built
this company that helps people unplug
and go off the grid the difference
between people when they checked in and
checked out was crazy they look 10 years
younger not only do you kind of the
changeable section on that but you also
get all the benefits of the kind of deep
sense of calm relaxation I went to one
of their cabins in the woods about a
year ago and TBH I didn't take it
seriously and I just sort of still had
my phone and stuff but now half of my
team have done this Cabin in the Woods
detox thing and they all swear by it and
so one of my action points from this
episode is to actually you know just try
and go somewhere and turn my phone off
for like three days and just see what
happens you could ask yourself an
unusual question which is like how am I
really feeling you know like how am I
doing if the answer is not good then you
know perhaps it's time to change
hey friends so before we get into the
episode I've got some very exciting news
that I'm finally able to share with you
and that is that I have written a book
now if you've been following the podcast
for a while you'll probably know from
some of my conversations with authors in
particular that has been quite the
journey over the last three years this
has been the single hardest thing that
I've ever done in my life but after
three years it's finally here and I'm
delighted to announce that my book feel
good productivity is now available for
pre-order it's going to be published
later this year and you can find a link
down in the video description or if you
head over to
feelgoodproductivity.com all one word uh
you can check out the website and the
website is absolutely sick now the
central idea for the book came from a
realization that I had while I was
working as a doctor a few years ago and
trying to juggle everything with my
YouTube channel and my business and I
kind of realized that the secret to
productivity isn't discipline it's in
fact joy and sure hard work and great
and willpower and determination and all
of those things are good in small doses
but for most of us they tend not to be
the sustainable route to consistent
productivity but I realized through a
lot of experimentation and then diving
into a bunch of research that actually
the secret to productivity that feels
enjoyable and meaningful and sustainable
is to find a way to make your work feel
good to find a way to make it feel
energizing and enjoyable and if you do
that you'll be more productive in your
work but you'll also have way more
energy to give to the other things in
your life that matter to you and this
isn't just my own personal experience
but it's an idea that's been validated
by a bunch of studies in the fields of
Psychology and Neuroscience as well and
so the writing process of the book over
the last three years has involved
reading hundreds of research papers
interviewing academics and experts in
the fields of like psychology and
procrastination and motivation and
spending years trying to condense it
into a format and cut out all the fluff
and try to do it in a way that's like
engaging and actionable at the same time
so that's what the book is about it is a
science back guide on how to do more of
what matters to you in a way that feels
enjoyable and meaningful and sustainable
and if you enjoy this podcast then I can
basically guarantee that you will love
the stuff that's in the book there are
nine chapters each chapter has six
different experiments in it that you can
try out in your own life and so there
are 54 different experiments strategies
that you can apply to your life starting
from as soon as you read the book and
the idea is that you apply these and you
see if they work for you and over time
you'll build your own feel-good
productivity system now if you do decide
to pre-order the book then that would be
awesome because firstly it helps me out
and secondly I think the ideas in this
book can be genuinely life-changing and
if you pre-order the book it will be
delivered straight to you on release
date later this year or to your Kindle
or your audible account and I'm
narrating the audiobook by the way uh or
to their hardback hardback version of
the book If you prefer to read physical
copies of books and if you do pre-order
then please do be sure to save your
receipts because I'm going to be
announcing a bunch of really exciting
pre-order bonuses exclusively not only
for people who pre-order the book and so
final thing before we get into the
episode is just want to say a massive
thank you to you guys by watching the
videos by subscribing on social media by
listening to the podcast you have made
this book possible without you guys
supporting the channel and everything
that I do there's no way penguin would
have come knocking and been like hey do
you want to write a book and so I'm like
this has been like such a rewarding
experience and I could not have gonna
come to this point without your support
so I just wanted to say massive thank
you from the bottom of my heart for that
so that's it from me do check out the
book If you like at
feelgoodproductivity.com it'll be linked
Down Below in the podcast description
and the show notes as well but now let's
get into the podcast episode itself
alright Hector welcome to the podcast
Ali great to be here so you have a
personal experience with burnout what's
the what's the story well after
University I joined a tech startup
honestly it was the only place uh I got
a job so applied to a whole bunch of
places didn't get any grad schemes and
then a friend of mine was like oh why
don't you go try and a startup so it
applied some startups one gave me a job
and joined as employee number nine and
it was iPad till system so if you go
into a restaurant or a cafe and use an
iPad for the till and we spent the next
three years doing the whole high growth
International expansion
did a whole bunch of roles during that
time fantastic experience in many ways
but you know we also got a lot of the
things wrong that startups tend to do so
culture was a bit of a mess product was
a bit of a mess so I just started to get
more and more worn down by that
experience and found that in 2019 after
three years of doing that it just
started to really lose my joy for life
so you know started to find I was
laughing less stressed more all of that
all of that kind of thing and I think
there was just like a deep
dissatisfaction because burnout can
show itself in many different ways right
you can have the complete uh you know
breakdown or actually there's just this
kind of slow grinding down which I think
is maybe more people are experiencing
and perhaps not recognizing that that
also needs to change right okay so for
me personally in 2019 really felt like I
needed to change and didn't didn't know
what to do a friend of mine recommended
a silent retreat in the Himalayas and I
I laughed it off much like much like you
haven't
I thought you know I just thought it was
the kind of thing I couldn't do you know
it's like uh what were the guys at work
thing I think I
you know in some ways I was so sure
about them but in some ways I really
wasn't and I had this like not quite
feeling comfortable with myself so
really
in hindsight a lot of what I did was
dictated by you know what other people
would think and that was just something
that didn't feel accessible to me
a couple of months went by and you know
I just became more and more
just just dissatisfied and eventually I
was like look I might as well go and try
it so September 2019 flew to the
Himalayas and it was this Buddhist
temple on top of mountain
and the best thing about it is when you
get there they take your phone off you
you spend 10 days cut off from the
outside world so came back from that you
know completely transformed and very
cliche but quit my job a week later and
to start unplugged which I know we can
go and talk about later down okay so
what what I guess what sort of symptoms
were you experiencing and what are the
signs now that you've actually been
working in the burnout industry I guess
like what are the signs that someone
watching or listening to this
might look out for to test or to assess
whether they are on the road to burnout
or like burned out or yeah yeah so so
after you know really kind of speaking
to a lot being also reflecting on myself
I think what it is you just stop feeling
that yourself you know like there's we
we can all stick back to when we're like
feeling at our best and kind of free us
and all of that kind of thing and
obviously life gets in the way but you
just feel like out of sorts you know you
feel you wake up every day and you're
not excited you know and I think that is
that is a big sign that your bird's out
and then that can go so much worse and
you can get people who have fully you
know stressed and having a breakdown but
really it's when you know you are not
yourself and you are not your best and I
think it's so normalized these days
we're obviously going to go on and talk
about phones Etc but I think the the
state that we're now in
as we are permanently out of sorts yeah
I think that's what's we're not
recognizing so I would say that you know
low-key burnout is is
very widespread I would say most people
are a little bit burnt out some people
are very burnt out yeah those people are
a little bit then okay but like
I'm gonna push back on this a little bit
surely waking up and not feeling excited
I imagine like most people who have jobs
don't wake up feeling excited does that
mean that they are low-key burned out or
just that they don't really know they
don't well the question is is it do not
feel decided on Monday morning or is it
do not feel excited every day you know
and I think most people are just not you
know they're just not kind of excited by
life
their life and that is goes on for
months you know and I think people feel
you hear phrases like I'm stuck in a rut
you know yeah and like what is that is
do you think that's a healthy way of
being uh absolutely not but I wonder if
it like
I've always been a bit confused about
the word burnout because to to an extent
it's become a little bit medicalized I
think the who is called burnout like the
burnout epidemic or some some something
to that effect and then the symptoms of
burnout often overlap with the symptoms
of depression and like low mood
generally but it's like at what point is
this a normal part of the human
experience that like uh you know I just
don't enjoy my job versus oh this is
something that I need to do something
about and I've I've never quite
understood the the distinction and at
what point someone should I guess
intervene if that makes sense for sure
well I want the other challenge there is
uh the normal human experience I think
that's changed and that's perhaps not a
healthy place right now
um but the other thing I would say is is
what gets you to that point of just like
not being excited and being uh just
dissatisfied with your life is just a
slow accumulation of stress you know
it's an accumulation of things it's not
just like hey you're doing something you
don't like because actually when we're
functioning at our best and we do
something that like we don't know then
you know it's it's kind of obvious and
we change it but I think the what's
happening slowly over time is we're just
being ground down by you know modern
society really and yes a lot of people
do jobs they hate for 40 50 years yeah
uh and maybe they maybe it's not a super
stressful job so they don't completely
flame out I think even the phrase
burnout right is very it's quite like
intense it's very it's very intense yeah
and so you think it needs to be this
like complete psychotic breakdown which
obviously does happen in the extreme
cases but I think you know like what is
a phrase right it's really as far as
it's useful so it's a tool it's it's you
know allowing us to reflect on work and
you know how we're doing with work
and So within that I think it's perhaps
more productive to have a wider
definition or a wider interpretation of
it right yeah because you know if
someone goes and
has a complete breakdown then that's
fairly obvious right but I think we need
to take a wide lens of like well all of
these people are building up this kind
of stress and dissatisfaction and
resentment frankly and to me that is a
sort of burnout and you know maybe it's
a use maybe it's a different phrase
that's needed there's less descriptive
but uh but I I think they need to be
looked at under the same umbrella okay
yeah yeah I think the when I think of
burnout I think of like the sort of like
oh you know yeah complete flame out like
can't move for two months kind of level
of burnout but actually if I think to
people that I know and people in my team
and sometimes maybe even me but like we
can talk about that
um it's you know there are more moments
more of like micro burnout or some yeah
so something to that effect that's not
quite that intense but still a minor
minor or major niggle of like
you know just a little bit of like not
enjoying things as much as I used to or
like feeling a bit like a what's a point
or feeling a bit like
yeah
yeah it's a sign you need a break right
and that's why it's useful because
that's where it's like that if someone
is burnt out then they just need a break
and to go and recharge and reflect it's
the right thing for them to be doing or
do they just need a holiday basically
and I think it's that it's you know when
people are just feeling not themselves
and for weeks on end then uh it's useful
to to
bring in this lens of like look this
person is a bit burnt out let's just
send them away for a bit and see what
happens yeah so what other questions
should someone ask themselves to see to
uh to assess whether they're like
on this micro burnout path well I think
the big question is like am I on my best
and if you're not then then why not
uh and do something about it because we
all really should be
you know striving for our best and as an
employer
um you know if you fundamentally want
your employees to turn up at their best
yeah and so I think there's just this
acceptance of like you know life is a
bit shitty and it's okay to like feel
bad all day and like that's fine because
you know job's a task and life is tough
and you know there are it is super
challenging yeah but
you know it shouldn't be
demoralizing and depressing uh and so I
think it's like
you know am I enjoying this you know
because if you're not enjoying it then
it's not sustainable
Okay so
I'm fully with you on this like I think
whatever whatever like a friend will say
to me that like oh you know Life's a bit
shitty but that's life right I'd be like
dude come on like why does it have to be
like this but also then the people the
the people I'm friends with are
generally the people I went to UNI with
who have a certain level of privilege
and are in high paying jobs where it's
easy enough for them to find another job
like there are tangible actions that
they could take whereas
if for example
like I knew lots of nurses back in the
day who were very burned out but they
can't just like quit their job and do a
career change as easily as I don't know
one of my finance Bros working at
Goldman Sachs making 150k a year so like
how did how do you think about
now that's that side of things 100 so
completely right like there is just you
know there are just lots of people who
have to do tough jobs that they hate
stressful jobs stressful environments
like being a nurse
um to make ends meet and maybe they
don't have the tools to suddenly start
loving their job but then perhaps it's
not their problem but it's the well it
is their problem but it's the employers
right it's like you have all these
people who are completely burnt out and
you know just just not at their best so
I think there is still a problem there
it's much harder for the person in that
situation to do something because it is
out of their hands to some extent I'm
not saying you know everyone can go and
you know yeah they're very slice of him
yeah exactly slightly and stuff because
it's just not that accessible both
psychologically and you know financially
and time wise um like a lot of people
just can't take two weeks off and but
but there is a systemic issue there you
know like I'm not here to kind of
hypothesize about what's going on inside
the the NHS but like the fact nurses are
so stressed and you look at lots of big
companies right there's lots of Goldman
Sachs
um got a lot of heat about it a couple
of years ago like those are systemic
issues inside those companies which is
very hard like when you have that many
people like all sorts of issues are
going to fly up and it's incredibly hard
to create an environment that doesn't
encourage that but what I'm saying is we
shouldn't normalize that you know it
shouldn't be like okay well this is just
fine because yeah exactly exactly so I
still think uh that there's big
opportunities to
help there and to you know really get
people out of that state but you know I
agree that it's it's much harder for
those people specifically but that being
said you know there is always things you
can do right like there's always
um you know you can work on yourself
there's a
there's a good uh slight tangent but
chess is a little bit a little bit far
out but uh chess used to be played
um where you always try and think what
your opponent would do a few moves ahead
right and then in the I think it was in
the 19th century some guy came along
it's like a child genius and he invented
this whole new type of Chess which is
something called positional chess which
all the grandmas in the world use today
which is instead of worrying too much
about what your opponent is doing you
just focus on your own position and I
think that is super
um super valuable to all of us because
it's like I think we spend a lot of time
you know frustrated and angry and upset
by what's going on outside and in the
world around us and it's actually like
if you just focus on yourself and your
position and your position is your
psychology your health all of these
things uh then you will turn up better
for for the other things as well so
again it's it's not it's not easy but
it's it's there
but when it comes to I guess causes of
burnout slash micro burnout are there
any other things that come to mind that
you see with the people that you deal
with other than overstimulation yeah for
sure so I mean a huge part of it is
people right like a company is just a
group of people really and so most most
problems if not all are people problems
and so I think a lot of burnout uh when
we talk about work comes from things
like feeling underappreciated or
resentment or any of these things and I
think you know we'll want to feel
special we all want to feel seen uh and
we all want to feel like we're doing a
good job and I think in companies today
again you have these very systemic
issues where people do feel
unappreciated uh they feel resentful
they feel like you know their boss is an
idiot or their boss is an idiot and I
think when you feel like something is
out of your control
then you get burnt out right it's when
things are in your control then you can
do something about them you can take
action but if we feel like things are
you know our life is being made
miserable by this person or by some
person way up the organization that we
can't even see then that's when a lot of
resentment Brews and I think that
resentment is super unhealthy and and
that can definitely cause Stress and
Anxiety and all of these things
yeah
yeah so I've got like um in my in my
upcoming book we've got three chapters
which are about overcoming burnouts and
one of the one of my Theses is for this
is
that I I think there are
three three kind of types of burnout
when I did a bunch of reading of the
literature and sort of thinking of
personal experience and stuff
the first one is
um over exertion burnout where you just
sort of constantly on the move and
constantly on the grind as it were and
just sort of exerting yourself too much
the second type is uh depletion burnout
where you've never you haven't quite
taken the time to recharge your energy
and I think that's the type where a
holiday really helps oh I feel all of a
sudden recharged and rejuvenated
but then the third type is um what I
call misalignment burnout where
everything might be fine but you're just
sort of chronically over time working
towards a future and is not actually
particularly aligned with where you you
authentically want to be
and
even if from the outside life looks good
and it's like you should be living the
dream and stuff when you start feeling
that chronic level of like I'm not
really sure what the point is that's a
sign that maybe there's some sort of
misalignment between your day-to-day
right now like your current actions and
the future that you actually want for
yourself but a future that you've
authentically chosen intrinsically
rather than one that's been foisted upon
you from the outside
um does that Vibe with your experience
at all yeah 100 I think the you know
what we spoke out about earlier which is
you know burnout
maybe in too broad a sense is when we're
not ourselves right we're not kind of
happier cells read a couple of books and
happiness one was um Flow by Mikhail
yeah something or other me and my chick
sent me high this one's called Happiness
hypothesis I read this about the same
time yeah and they both made the point
that happiness comes for them when
everything in your life is aligned you
know so what you're doing in your job
who you spend your time with your values
Etc and so I guess it's that sense of
when you are not happy
then by definition you're unhappy right
and so I think misalignment really you
know breeds unhappiness and you know
that causes the other types right like
yeah either over strained because you
feel like you're trying too hard against
something you know when you really love
something it doesn't feel like work at
all you know it feels like play and so I
think those other types of burnout
perhaps come from you know something
being misaligned or something being
wrong uh so I think that
you know it's really just about
looking at the person and it's like
am I happy right now
you know is is that the right way like I
feel like happy often has like very like
oh well I'm happy when I'm drinking with
the boys or when I'm playing video get
like yeah well I think you know
every word is
different to everyone right and so I
think again it's like what's useful and
you're right you're right I think happy
you know what is happiness is such a
contentious issue there's no yeah
perhaps content is a better word right
yeah I like content and tranquil yeah
like yeah Serene yeah or you could ask
yourself an unusual question which is
like how am I really feeling you know
like how am I doing and if the answer is
not good then you know perhaps it's time
to change
how am I really do it that's what I like
that's what Steve Bartlett likes to ask
in the guests to be like how are you
really and then they'll just start
crying it's like oh god oh my god well I
think I'd be alone in the sound of that
pent-up emotion in this this
episode is very kindly brought to you by
huel I've been using hula I've been a
pain customer over here since 2017 and
since my fifth year of medical school
when I first discovered it and basically
what it is if you haven't heard of it is
that it is a meal in a shake it got the
perfect balance of carbs and fiber and
proteins and fat and it contains 26
different vitamins and minerals all you
do is add water or milk to the powder
usually I use water you can shake it up
or you can blend it I prefer to blend
and then it becomes a fantastic option
if you're like me and you're kind of
busy and so you don't really have time
for breakfast or lunch my favorite
version is the heel black edition it's
absolutely sick 400 calories 40 grams of
protein for 400 calories I'm trying to
get Hench and it's actually pretty hard
to find something that has such a high
protein content for such a low calorie
trade-off and so I really like using the
heel black edition to start my mornings
off it's vegan it's gluten-free it's
lactose free the Black Edition is
available in nine flavors my favorite
sauce a caramel and I wouldn't recommend
having every single meal heal because
that gets a bit annoying after a while
but it's absolutely fantastic it's like
one of the meals of the day especially
if you're busy and you're gonna kind of
default to something unhealthy otherwise
it's also very affordable so it actually
works out to one pound 68 per meal for a
400 calorie meal which is just
incredible value and actually way
cheaper than other generic protein
shakes on the market and it saves a
bunch of time because it's so quick and
easy to make and so it's particularly
exciting that they're sponsoring the
podcast and actually we have the founder
of huel Julian Hearn who was on the very
first season of the podcast that was a
sick episode that got so many rave
reviews as well anyway if you're
interested in trying out huel then head
over to heal.com forward slash Deep dive
and if you use that URL a it really
helps me out but B you also get a free
t-shirt and also a free Shaker that
comes with your order so go to heal.com
forward slash deep dive that will also
be linked down in the video description
or the show notes and thank you so much
heal for sponsoring this episode this
episode is very kindly brought to you by
trading212. now people ask me all the
time for advice about investing because
I've made a bunch of videos about it on
the YouTube channel and my advice for
most people is generally invest in Broad
stock market index funds which is
exactly what you can do completely for
free with trading 212. it's a great app
that lets you trade stocks and funds and
ETFs and foreign exchange if you really
want to and one of the great things
about the app is that if you're new to
the world of investing you can actually
invest with fake money you don't have to
put real money in they've got a practice
mode where you invest fake money and
then it actually tracks what the market
is doing in real time so you can see had
I invested 100 pounds into this thing
what would my return have been X weeks
or X months further down the line once
you've got some comfort with that then
it's super easy to deposit money into
your trading tube into account you can
use Apple pay like I do initially or you
can use a direct bank transfer and then
once the money is in your trading 212
account then you can invest it in
basically whatever you want now if
you're based in the UK you might be
familiar with the concept of an Isa
which is an individual savings account
which is basically a tax-free wrapper
that you can put money in you can put
twenty thousand pounds in every year up
to twenty thousand pounds and it resets
every April and then all that money can
grow and it's completely tax-free for
the rest of your life and if you want to
sign up for an iso you can sign up for
one completely for free also on trading
212. so if you haven't yet filled up
your eyes allowance or at least put some
money into your Isa for this year that
might be a good step forward also very
excitingly there's a new feature that
they've added to the app which is a
daily interest on your uninvested cash
these interest rates may go up or down
over time as the economic environment
changes but the cool thing is that you
get paid out every single day if you're
into that sort of thing the app also
lets you Auto invest which is a great
thing because then you can automatically
invest a percentage of your paycheck
into the thing every month and so if you
haven't yet started with investing and
you want to give it a go then you can
download the app on the App Store and if
you use the coupon code Ali Ali it will
give you a totally free share worth up
to 100 pounds it's available on iPhone
and Android and you can check it out by
typing in trading 212 into your
respective App Store so thank you so
much trading 212 for sponsoring this
episode I'm not particularly good at
feeling my feelings this is a thing that
I'm working I had the same oh okay same
feedback recently oh interesting from my
girlfriend so what was that what was the
story if you don't mind sharing
um
gosh a couple of occasions
she's she's brought it up a few times
yeah I think as has uh I started seeing
a therapist recently which has been
transformational she brought up the same
challenge me on the same thing yeah and
one of my closest friends as well as
I've heard it for a few different angles
um and I think people have like
encouraged me to be more emotional in
situations and I've reflected on it and
really kind of thought about it for
example it's just just little things
like my parents cat died who I spent a
lot of time in my childhood and I'm like
told my girlfriend she was like well
you're really not emotional are you and
um
I don't know like part of me like feels
a little bit like I should be you know
crying I you know love the cat great cat
s and there are there are times when you
know I do cry as well so I think but
yeah I think
I have been reflecting about this I'm
like gosh is there something broken in
me and actually I I really like again I
think stoics get a bit of a bad
reputation in society because it's like
you know just kind of get on with it
type thing but I don't think it's about
that I think it's about reframing a
situation you know there is good in
every situation and I think if I look at
myself one of my my best it's when I
have that kind of you know glass half
full mentality of like the yeah sure
this is something's going wrong but like
we'll learn from this you know there's a
great Jocko willink video where uh it's
a three minute video about good it's
like you know one of his guys comes with
an issue and he's always just like well
good it will and and this guy's like I
know what you're gonna say to me and
he's like
you're just gonna say good I said yeah
well it is good great video uh but I
think that really
applies well like you can have this this
glass awful mentality because there is
good in every situation I look at my own
life and like where I've already you
know got it wrong like I had I'm 28 now
and had a decade from 15 to 25 when
didn't take my life too seriously I
drunk a lot done a lot of stupid stuff
and actually it was really getting it
wrong that is kind of fueling you know
everything I'm doing now and the
positive changes I've made in my life
and I think if I hadn't been if I'd been
a bit less stupid in those days then the
reaction wouldn't have been as uh as
kind of extreme to some extent with an
extremely unpositive way you know like
I've really taken the time to uh like
learn myself you know give myself the
tools to
be happy I think we'll be content be
content so yeah yeah how about you how
does it show up
if I if I ask myself how am I really
like my default response is just like
yep fine things things are good things
are great like
yep I I almost struggle to struggle to
put feelings into words or to even feel
the feelings at all
um and this is something that I started
working on with a therapist as of this
week so like three days ago I had my
first like session as part of this eight
week program because apparently it's
really common for uh dudes in particular
to be quite disconnected from bodily
feelings and to just sort of live in the
mind yeah sort of be a mind walking
around in a body but not really
connecting with the body at all
um and
and so I've been trying to figure out
like what are the questions that so I
think like asking asking asking a
powerful question is often the way to
sort of get it truth or Insight or
something
and so when I ask myself you know how am
I feeling it's like
I don't like it doesn't yeah it doesn't
really register as like fine but yeah
but like I discovered a guy called Peter
Crone recently I don't know if you come
back oh you'd love this yeah you're
right fully right up your street
um he is he he he goes by the Mind
architect he's like the British guy who
ended up being a celebrity personal
trainer in the US and flying around with
Tom Cruise and Nicole Kidman and stuff
and training them and then he trains
like Olympians and stuff and he's got
like you know the physiology physical
side but he's also done a lot of
spiritual stuff and understands like the
Indian tradition of like vedanto
whatever the hell it's called and just
combined it all into one to sort of and
his whole thing is he
grandiose but like liberates people from
the shackles of their own mind yeah and
he does it in a very nice kind of
British accent kind of way you know this
guy in his probably 40s
and it's a really cool like there's all
these epic podcast episodes where he's
he's a guest on a podcast and the host
is like some big Hench like Joker
willink-esque character and they just
break down in tears because he's like he
also just like one pointed question yeah
so cool uh why did I get onto this um I
got onto this because one of his
questions is well one of his things is
that life will
um life will confront you with
situations and people that will reveal
where you're not free 100th us so wide
and so I liked it um so recently in the
last like two weeks I've been asking
myself a question of like where in in
what way am I currently not free
and that that's a great question makes
me think oh okay
I can think of lots of things for that
but if asked how how I'm feeling I'm
like fine I guess but how am I not free
oh hello okay I care too much about view
counts on YouTube I don't care too much
I care too much about these
sponsorship deadlines and like I feel
the sense of like having to jump from
this thing to this thing to this thing
because the calendar is over chocolate
oh okay nice
but how am I feeling I don't know I
think I think about it and I did a um
there's this sort of longevity lab in
California called everspan life which I
ended up working with uh and I had so
they did a load of blood tests on me and
I had like last night
um I had my zoom session with one of
their doctors who was talking me through
my blood results
and he was like you know have you got a
particularly stressful job and I was
like no yeah I'm chill I'm a YouTuber I
can do whatever the hell and he was like
well your stress markers are a little
bit higher than we would expect I was
like what I was like yeah you know this
this one and this one and that one this
one it was like and he was like has
anyone ever told you that you should
take a break I was like yeah and he was
like do you meditate at all I was like
no it was like have you tried but failed
yeah
and I'd really you know even if someone
asked me now you know do you have a
stressful job I think hell no like I
make videos on the internet and do
podcasts like my friends have stressful
jobs they're working in the NHS for
God's sake
and yet
everyone in my life would say I should
probably take a break and if I ask
myself where am I not free I would look
at the calendar and just sort of show
the person the calendar and it's weird
because
I have control over my time like I I
have way more control over my life than
like almost anyone in the world and yet
I've convinced myself that like
I don't know this is what I want that
I'm totally fine but the blood markers
are not are telling a different story
The Calendar's telling a different story
my friends are telling a different story
so I think I've recently started to
realize
as I say there's that like I'm probably
bullshitting myself to an extent in
convincing myself that actually
happy days I have to do it you know
everything is awesome interesting the
The Lego Movie yeah
um yeah does any of that land with you
100 I think I think that's a really
interesting point uh for a lot of
entrepreneurs myself included because
you know people ask me why am I doing
this and it's very much you know I
really care about the mission we're
driving and you know I really want I
think Society is a lot more malleable
than we think and we have a real
opportunity to kind of change the
direction of that so I do care about all
of that but then if I'm really being
honest with myself there's that little
bit of like you know needing to show I'm
remarkable you know and I think there's
a very human thing
uh because I guess to some of your
points that like view count Etc the
question is like
what's your narrative if you're not
doing so well on that right so if you're
feeling bad because you know the views
didn't go up so much this month or for
me it might be you know our Revenue
numbers or whatever it is
um or gross cabins then like what is
that narrative there is this this like
you know
I don't know this kind of frustration
that we're not like showing everyone how
like amazing we are or whatever it is
how special they are there's something
about being human where we just really
want to feel
um feel special so I think that
you know that that question is fantastic
and it does get to the point of you know
perhaps these behaviors that we are
normalizing on as
aren't as healthy as we think and it's
super interesting that you say that
everyone around you would tell you that
you need a holiday but it's not
something that you feel you know uh and
because I think what does it really come
back to kind of like burnout I think
another loaded word that is
um also at the root of pretty much
everything is is trauma right
trauma's a big one and uh I think again
it's like where are our traumas and like
how do they show are we in trauma kind
of like burnout you you picture this
like car burning out and like very
dramatic and like trauma you picture
some terrible thing happening during
your childhood and I think trauma or you
know where it's relevant here is broader
than that right it's like anything that
happened to us as a child yeah that
might have been just like one little
offhand comment yep that you know for
some reason made a massive effect on
this and that shows up all through our
life and so I actually had
um an experience about a year or two
into running uploads kind of like this
where I felt like I'd I felt like I
cracked life so I was stupid to say but
you know I was I was kind of had really
built a strong meditation habit I was
reading a lot I was like feeling super
chilled unplugged was going well and I
was like I you know I think I figured
out happiness you know I'm just I'm just
happy now and uh and then you know life
life came and and kind of got more
complicated but more difficult and we
started growing and I got into a
relationship still with uh with K now
he's wonderful and that's been but that
has been a challenge for me because like
that's a particular area where I have
trauma so actually uh start of 2020 I
think I did four months or something
called psychosexual therapy oh hello
yeah so it's basically sex and
relationships therapy okay and I had up
until that point I never made it past
two months in relationships I'd always
like I'd feel this like deep sense of
claustrophobia
um and like you know literally within a
couple of weeks into relationship and
then I I just like felt at building and
building building and then I'd have to
like Cut and Run and so
and then around the time starting
unplugged I quit drinking around that
time it was the pandemics I was like I'm
just not going to worry about
relationships for a year or something so
it must have been started 2021 and uh
and then I
saw listen to a podcast with a
psychosexual therapist which I'd never
heard of before and I was like that's
probably something I could do with so I
did four months of Psychosocial therapy
and basically got to the bottom that it
was all kind of stems from like Teenage
anxieties around sex and just like I
think not having confidence of like how
to
to any of it at the age of like
14 15. yeah feeling like I was behind
perhaps yeah
um and and that then in hindsight fueled
the drinking so I started drinking about
the age of 15 and like that was almost a
party trick for a decade it was like
well let's just see how drunk I can get
and it's funny and you know people seem
to like me if I do that and that kind of
thing and so I think that
um
I really built a life on that kind of
pretty shaky insecure ground so on the
surface and if you'd asked me if I was
happy then I would have told you I was
happy yeah and but it was built on this
like
escaping from my trauma
and it was only
kind of really sitting down and and
always actually was only going through a
couple of relationships and realizing
just how in relationships but two months
of dating realizing just how big an
issue it was for me
um did I kind of reflect there's an
issue here so I did the psychosexual
therapy a month later I met uh Kay my
girlfriend and you know straight off the
bat that was fantastic completely
different I think because I had that
awareness and like awareness of myself
and like the issues of myself but then
you know we have also been through
difficult periods so
started living together pretty quickly
she runs a startup as well so like
there's that kind of tension at times
and uh and it is difficult you know it's
and so it was a very humbling experience
for me because I'd come from this place
of like life's so easy to like oh my
gosh life throws curb it wasn't you know
we're not even talking about kids all
that kind of stuff I could only imagine
uh how complicated life gets once you go
down that route so I think
the more
the more kind of um I guess
strain or even stimulus or you know
things going on in your life the more
likely you are to kind of trigger one of
those traumas that's still something I'm
working on yeah she's case great and
super open about it so we we chat about
it a lot and you know both doing therapy
um so and and that has been that has
been
pretty helpful like I was chatting to my
therapist a couple of weeks ago and just
voicing like oh gosh you know we kind of
went through
a tougher patch and I said yeah it was
just this like fear but I might make a
mistake all this kind of thing she was
like
and I was like looking for her to be
like well you know is this the right
thing for you blah blah blah but she was
actually like it sounds like you know
it's just your fit like what if you just
turn down you're fit and just stop
questioning everything and that was
super empowering and I stepped away from
that and I was like it just felt like 10
times lighter you know so
it's interesting where we can go through
these periods to get past the original
point of feeling like we're fine and we
don't have any issues but actually deep
within us there are these traumas that
are just waiting to come out at some
other point in life so yeah that's
that's been my own journey I guess with
the trauma
thank you for being so open about this
marriage awesome
that's a powerful question what if you
just turned down your fear yeah
what other insights did you have from
the from the therapist psychosexual
therapist psych research therapist um
I mean the same thing like it's the same
thing as the therapist I'm saying now is
a different therapist and uh it's the
same thing which is like maybe it's not
the outside world you know maybe it's
you're worrying about the situation that
is causing the issues you know so maybe
you just stop worrying
then there's no more issues it's like
overthinking you know kind of it's all
this question it becomes like a
self-fulfilling prophecy
so and it's actually the same to the the
silent Retreat I did post post burnout
starting unplugged uh it was a it's
called intro to Buddhism so it was hard
meditation half Buddhist philosophy
and uh it was the same thing which is
like you know the the kind of core idea
of Buddhism is that like all of the
suffering all of our suffering comes
from ourself right like not the outside
work like we think most people most of
us most of the time think that the issue
is a boss or you know this person or
this thing and actually that is not the
issue the issue is how you react to it
and so like again that's a very
empowering idea because if it's like hey
maybe I'm the problem here and you do
that in a kind way right you're not like
damn you Ali you know you're the problem
here it's like uh well Hector um it's
like
the problem is me but that's good it
means I I can work on it you know I can
sort it but yeah it's super helpful like
I think having someone point that out to
you because I think we are just
and we'll have blind spots all of the
time and you know you look back I think
it's so interesting to look back at
yourself a few years ago you're like wow
I've learned so much but then if we look
forward a few years we're like oh no but
I'm probably not gonna learn that I
probably don't know most of it now yeah
but it'll be the same again for sure
yeah the end of History illusion
where we think oh I've changed a lot in
the last five years but like like surely
I mean surely I'm at my final evolution
like there's no way I'm gonna change
that much in the next five years like
I'm kind of I'm kind of where I'm I need
to be
so was there a specific moment when you
were a teenager that you can that you
sort of traced back to where kind of
these insecurities and the fears stemmed
from it's a very deep question
um it's Deep dive
I think I'm honest it was just like a
like a a feeling like I'm sure there
were lots of like little occasions but
it was just a real like laughing of
self-confidence there and just like not
feeling like I knew so you know when
people started dating all that kind of
thing just like not even know where to
start with that you know so it wasn't
like a flirty kid or teenager and like
just didn't know how to uh do that to be
honest and I think was kind of
maybe like later going through puberty
Etc I was like tiny until the age of
about 15 and so I I just think it all
compounded
in but you know on one hand I had this
real self-confidence in myself in some
areas but then on the other hand I just
had this real
uh yeah just just like not being
comfortable with my own skin and just
like not really knowing
you know how to engage with dating and
relationships Etc and you felt like the
people around you knew how to do that
stuff yeah yeah yeah so everyone else
had figured out and I was click this
yeah do you think that that was true if
I don't think that was true in hindsight
but only the only time I haven't thought
that was true is when you just asked me
that okay I've never reflected back I've
been like hey that probably wasn't true
but it took you to answer ask that
question to come to that conclusion yeah
I think there's a lot of a lot of
occasions where
yeah where you know I do I do this a lot
I'll I'll tell myself a story
about something and it's only like ages
later that I'm like if someone asked the
question I'm like hang on that story
that I was telling myself
perhaps wasn't true yeah
um
like I remember one time so my brother
and I have a podcast that we sort of
pseudo do some of the time and we at one
point we interviewed one of my friends
his name is Jake he's like classic lad
like muscles football team
I'm drinking a lot you know the The
Stereotype of like you know a lot I mean
he was also a Cambridge Medical student
so it's like you know there's there's
like you know levels of that and we were
interviewing him about what it's like to
be a lot because my brother and I were
like massive nerds and we just never had
experienced this and
it was it was quite like it was quite
eye opening because he was like yeah I
mean you know he felt insecure as well
in parties thinking that like everyone
else knew and had it figured out and he
was like he would be like yeah you know
if I just drink more then
then I'll have a good time and
he this was sort of many years after we
all graduated from University and he he
said that he's just he he has since
spoken to friends from that time of his
life who he felt were ladier than he was
and he realized that they were all
insecure about how Lady they were and
whether they were truly having fun but
like going along with it because it's
what everyone did
and
when you're in the moment it's so easy
to
yeah it's so easy to just think that
everyone else has it figured out and
I'm the problem with me kind of thing
yeah I think I think you would if you
looked hard enough you would find
insecurity at the
the root of most things you know like
that little even you know what you
perhaps Challenge on and and me
um on the kind of views thing on YouTube
absolutely yeah and you know I think
every entrepreneur probably does have
some insecurity in them still somewhere
uh and you know maybe you need I listen
to I don't know if you listen to James
Watt and Steve Bartlett's podcast oh no
I haven't listened to that one yet
really interesting he spoke about how he
has this voice permanently on his
shoulder telling him he's not good
enough you know which came from his
mother but uh and yeah that's an extreme
example you know mask another extreme
example you know like tougher issue with
his father bullied at school all that
kind of thing
um and you know sometimes I do think you
need that
just level of needing to prove yourself
to go and do the like really you know
outsize things you know like the the
kind of napoleons and the Elon Musk of
the world right I do think I do think
you can build something big impactful
etc etc
um from a positive place as well but I
think the real outliers there probably
is there probably is some insecurity
deeper um deeper the core some kind of
pain that's driving us yeah careful what
you wish for you know but Elon as well
is famous for saying I'm not sure you'd
want to be me and it's like it's not so
great
yeah I wonder like as we were talking
about kind of views and revenue numbers
and stuff
like I was thinking of
like
I think we all and I certainly do we we
all Peg our self-worth to certain things
yeah and
I think I mean for me growing up I fully
pegged my self-worth to my grades and my
ranking of the Year group obviously you
know I I couldn't compete on the lad
front or a sports team's front so it's
like great
you know I am the guy who comes top of
the air academically and my entire
self-worth was sort of picked to that
and then at University
I realized oh like
it would be a lot of work to continue to
make myself work of myself Worth to that
and uh that's not really working anymore
and so
of that insecurity or feeling probably
probably feeling in fact I can just drop
the probably that insecurity of feeling
not good enough
not worthy enough to be accepted
is what prompted me to start
my first business at University I mean I
started it because I got scammed out of
a thousand pounds and I used a million
thousand pounds back once I made a
thousand pounds back yeah then the next
10 and the next 100 and the next
whatever that was a sense of like oh I
might not be the smartest person in the
ear group or the one with the best grade
but I'm doing business on the side
Checker yeah and five years later that
morph into the YouTube channel where all
of a sudden this is like a whole other
game to play where it's sort of chasing
like daily dopamine hits of self-worth
and self-validation and self like
affirmation almost where it's like every
new subscriber is a new Boost to the ego
every new viewers boost of the ego every
comment being like Oh my God I love you
you've changed my life is a boost of the
ego every comment that's this is
terrible what are you talking about it's
like a massive like which so it is like
there's a lot of
you know one thing when things are going
well and the numbers are going up and
the line is going up then it's very easy
to think that like
I'm a chill guy I've read all the stoses
and books life is good yeah but it's
when the numbers start to go down that
truly tests
that that thing appeared that Peter
Crone would say
it reveals where you're not free yeah
and I found all my first business where
you know I used to run courses for
medical admissions
for the first three years the numbers
kept going up and I felt like on top of
the world and then year four the numbers
plateaued and then year five went down a
bit and I was like oh my God and that
was you know led to a lot of journaling
and reflection and that's why I started
my blog and I think my very first post
on that blog is like trying to come to
terms with the fact that the numbers are
going down and deciding what I want to
do about it which was ultimately what
prompted the YouTube channel to start
but
I think yeah I think we all Peg our I I
certainly do and I I wonder if people
listening to this can relate but
pegging our self-worth to certain
numbers and certain things yeah and I
think to bring it right back that's
probably one of the many uh
issues I would say that that phone's
course right is like it's that on
steroids oh yeah because it is
challenging your self-worth all day
every day you know even the people
pleasing thing we mentioned earlier like
I think you and I are probably quite
similar we have this narrative in our
minds like we're a nice guy yeah and so
you feel like if you're not replying to
this person this challenge yourself
worse you know yeah
um and you know the again comes back to
the overstimulation where there's just
too much going on so that it's just it's
just pulling away at us have you read No
More Mr Nice Guy that hasn't no that's
really good you wouldn't love it yeah
okay so Peter Crone plus Noah Mr Knife
Guy he would fully highlight the
shipment of that though that's so good I
I first read it like 10 years ago and
I've reread it every few years since and
every time I've taken so much away from
it because it's like I stand still
fundamentally trying to people please
yeah because there is some sort of
insecurity in me that's like I'm not
worthy I'm not good enough why would
anyone accept me as I am I have to
perform to be liked and craving being
liked is like core part of like what I
want yeah and so whether it's at being
at University or being being a doctor or
being a YouTuber or being in a
relationship there's like so many
instances of life where for me at least
the the people-pleasing tendency comes
up
in running the team where it's like I
don't want to give negative feedback to
someone because I don't want to think to
dislike me for that one moment yeah and
then
six months later it's like I wish
I'd told them and told on this because
they could have changed something and
they're like yeah how the hell didn't
you tell me I'm like because I wanted to
be a nice guy oh no yeah it's all yeah
it all comes down to the
down to the freedom
um
you said you so this silent Retreat
he said it was partly introduction to
Buddhism partly meditation what was the
like did you have any experience of this
sort of stuff before or was that your
first experience and what was what was
that experience like yeah for sure so I
guess to take it back further uh during
my time
so again you said kind of
drink a lot not tell if you seriously
got a job at this startup and that was
actually a very transformational
experience because For the First Time I
started to engage with something I was
pretty rubbish at all the jobs I was
doing was like the sales Ram product for
you around growth for a year and I was
like I was pretty bad at each job but I
think that was quite good in the startup
environment you know it was like quite
good at navigating the people said
something bright occasionally so I think
that was very engaging and then it just
started to become this like bigger and
bigger conflict this kind of on one on
one side living this like you know kind
of boozy lifestyle and on the other side
I was actually starting to like enjoy
something and engage with something and
to start to you know read a lot more uh
so this is the podcast all that kind of
thing and that introduced me to
meditation and it was like well it I
just had it come up again again and
again like everyone's like you know all
these people who seem to have it figured
out it was like oh they also meditate so
I was like okay this is probably
something worth trying did headspace for
a while
um which I think is a great intro to
meditation but I found it's quite hard
work like it's uh you know the focus on
the breath I found you know for one
month it would go well and then I'd kind
of be a bit lazier with a month and for
all of the people who talk about
meditation it's actually quite rare to
have as a daily practice and people
actually do it every day and then I came
across something called Transcendental
Meditation in summer
2019 and that was it's very big in like
Hollywood you know it's in people like
Hugh Jackman and Ellen all these kind of
people and it was like they're the
busiest people if it works for them then
maybe it's worth trying so
I learned that there's a four day
induction went to an unmarked house in
Shepherd's Bush you have to bring a
flower a white handkerchief and a piece
of fruit so it feels a little bit culty
but then you get given a mantra
basically a meaningless Mantra and uh
and that's it you just sit there for 20
minutes twice a day just repeating this
mattress yourself and that was
completely transformative sorry
yeah and the the main reason is because
it's really easy to make it stick and
the reason behind that is just so all of
this Buddhist mindfulness meditation is
designed for monastic living so life in
a monastery right so it's quite hard
work by by its nature whereas this is
designed for for Lay people and so it's
just much easier to to make a habit of
it
and if you do any kind of meditation 20
minutes twice a day but then what this
does is it like lulls you into the state
of relaxation so I don't know it's just
like really a really vividly remember
that first week just being like Oh my
God you know 90 of the work I'm doing is
absolutely nonsense basically like so
just really gave me a lot of clarity on
life wait so just by repeating this
Mantra to yourself for 20 minutes twice
a day yeah by meditating to doing this
Mantra 20 minutes twice a day so what
does that look like like if you were to
sort of pseudo coach me like I've never
done this before like what yeah what
would it look like if you were to talk
me or whoever's listening through
through actually doing the meditation
yeah for like I don't know two minutes
or something like that yeah for sure for
sure so the I I can't give you my
manager because it's a secret yeah
apparently you're not allowed to tell
yeah and the reason behind that is if I
then meditating later I'll remember this
conversation so you know when I'm saying
the Mantra so okay uh or should we make
one up that's it
almost like a classic one is a classic
one it's a classic one yeah it's
something to do the words they choose is
something to do with like the vibrations
like you can feel the resonance that's
the right word in your body so it's
something about that okay and uh so what
you're literally just doing is you're
literally just sitting there and
literally just in my clothes yeah close
your eyes okay I'm gonna close my eyes
and just think to yourself oh
I am just think that for two minutes and
if you lose the Mantra then don't worry
when you realize then you just start
doing it again
so I'm just thinking on to myself so for
like two minutes so don't try too hard
to concentrate on it okay
okay we're just gonna try this out
actually like
two minutes that's two minutes my phone
is still registering and I'll do a walk
oh apparently I walk for two hours
okay on for two minutes
that was that was interesting but it's I
don't know how you found it compared to
like focus on your breath meditation but
it's more of like a more like a nap than
a let's say you actually fall asleep but
it's like you're kind of lulling
yourself into this state of relaxation
yeah rather than like the hard work of
of focusing on your breath yeah I did
find it was easier because I was just
like um
my bear is wearing the focus on
breathing I've tried it a few times that
it's like
quite a lot of mental effort to like
really focus on the breath and the sort
of rising and falling of the chest and
all that stuff yeah and they do various
different things to the mind so
meditation is effectively a tool right
it's like all the different types of
meditation and different tools so I mean
you know I'm sure you know a time about
neuroplasticity and how the brain
changes but you can imagine and it comes
back to scrolling on your phone right
but you can imagine what focusing on
your breath does versus that where it
kind of lulls you into the state state
of rest and it's doing very different
things to the Mind likewise
visualization is another type of
meditation or like you know something
called analytic analytical meditation
when you're like focusing on different
points in your body so all doing very
different things
and but
fundamentally would that will help you
helping you do it's like become more
present become more balanced uh and you
know just get a better control of
yourself and your emotions versus
scrolling on your phone for five hours
you know you can imagine what scrolling
through social media is doing to our
minds so I think that is another huge
thing we underestimate which is
everything you do during the day is a
votes
on where you want your mind to go and
you're moving yourself in that direction
and we've just slipped especially with
code that we've just kind of slipped
into this habit of just like what is
we're switching switching between
devices and just it's a much shallower
uh just way of living
I'm delighted to say that this podcast
is very kindly sponsored by 80 000 hours
and 80 000 hours is one of my favorite
organizations in the world they are a
non-profit that helps people have a more
positive impact with their career and
the reason they're called 80 000 hours
is because a career is on average 80 000
hours long it's around 40 hours a week
for 50 weeks a year for around 40 years
which adds up to 80 000 hours that's a
very very long time until the objective
of 80 000 hours is to help you find a
fulfilling career that also has a
positive impact in the world and the
best part is there are complete
non-profit they are not trying to make
any money from this at all and so the
organization is sick I've interviewed a
bunch of their members here on this
podcast and they've literally spent the
last decade conducting a bunch of
research around what makes a career
fulfilling and also what makes a career
positively impactful in the world
they've been doing this research
alongside academics at places like
Oxford University and actually for me
personally when I was struggling to
figure out what to do with my career I
basically binged every single post on 80
000 hours.org which is the website and I
also had a careers counseling session
with one of their careers counselors and
those two things just like reading all
this stuff understanding what are the
factors that actually lead to an
impactful career and how can I combine
those with my own personal passions and
skills really helped me to formulate
that actually this career as being a
thought leader YouTuber podcast or
whatever I'm doing now I actually felt
more meaningful and impactful for me
than continuing to be a doctor so yeah
everything they provide is completely
free they're a non-profit and their only
aim is to help you find a fulfilling and
impactful career and if you want to get
a completely free copy of their in-depth
career guide then head over to 80 000
hours.org forward slash Deep dive and if
you enter your email over there again
completely for free they're not trying
to make any money from this if you enter
your email they will send you the career
guide which is basically the crash
course in the main ideas that make for a
fulfilling and high impact career so
head to 80 000 hours.org that's eight
zero zero zero zero hours hoors.org
forward slash deep dive and that will
give you so much more information on how
to start planning or changing your
career to something that's fulfilling
and meaningful and has a positive impact
on the world so thank you so much 80 000
hours for very kindly sponsoring this
episode
and while I was saying the alms there
were some Just Thoughts coming up
and some other instances where you know
that conversation we're having about
people pleasing where I realized like
two very specific instances where in the
last well one of them was like yesterday
the album was like a year ago that I
just hadn't really thought about this
came to mind where I was like yeah in
that situation I was people pleasing and
didn't operate doing what I
authentically wanted to do and instead
what I thought a nice guy or a good man
would do in that context which is
sacrifice mode preferences for although
perceived preferences of someone else
for sure yeah yeah because I think
that's it it's about
like also just developing our
self-awareness right I think we are so
unself-aware by default and yet
especially when we have this
overstimulated mind we're not present
right like when you're on your phone
you're thinking you're not thinking
about yourself you're thinking about
that person whose social media post
you've just seen or that person who's
messaged you
um so you're very not tuned in to
yourself and I think it's by tuning into
yourself which obviously meditation is a
great way of doing but really any time
Offline that you can start to come up
with these things and you can start to
better answer you know that question
around like how you really how are you
really doing like things start to come
up yeah
yeah because I guess the this morning as
well like I generally I generally make
it a point not to check my phone first
thing in the morning because it's just
such such good and standard advice but
this morning I was like you know last
night I was listening to an Alex Hall
Mosey talk which is like an hour and a
half long and I was like you know what
that was really good I'm going to
continue listening to it and then a
friend messaged me that link to that
same talk saying skip to timestamp 32
minutes because this is so you and I was
like cool let's go 32 minutes listen to
her double speed realized oh yeah this
is me in the business and it's like yeah
suddenly I'm like all right you know
I've got the airpods in going to the
toilet brushing my teeth and I'm like
yeah listing a double speed and have all
these thoughts coming in my mind around
like all right cool interesting things
we can do in the business and then I
think you know what I'm gonna go for a
walk so you're gonna get the morning
sunlight into you know as Andrew
huberman would recommend yeah you know
walk down to the local premon Jay get
some you know I get a cheeky coffee but
on the walk I'm listening to an online
course that I'm taking at Double speed
because I'm like oh more stuff more
stuff in the business like yes yeah and
just like actually taking the space to
it if it feels so okay people go
it just feels so unproductive to not to
not to be doing 100 It Feels So
unproductive just sit there yeah for 20
minutes SoMo right it's like I need to
listen to this talk right now I could be
missing out on this like value that's
just been uploaded to YouTube yeah I
think that is the key point is like that
is very tangible value right listen to
it yeah so amazing to talk exactly
you're gonna get some great insights
right what is not tangible is the value
of going for a walk and not listening to
anything you know because
you know it's much less certain that
there's like two modes of thinking
there's Focus thinking diffuse think I'm
sure you've come across this in your
travels but focusing is the spotlight so
the Alexi talks you're thinking about
what he is saying yeah
um but actually where the magic really
happens is diffuse thinking and it's
when you switch off the conscious mind
and you do something like go for a
stroll you've got kind of light uh you
know the light movement that's keeping
us a little bit engaged but we don't
have to think too much about it we've
got the blood flow into the brain
and it allows our subconscious mind to
start just drawing interesting ideas
which is why when you go for a long walk
with with nothing
you know ideas pop up you didn't even
know you didn't even know you're
thinking about that problem right and a
solution just pops up so I think we yeah
could benefit a huge amount from
spending more time in in that state and
I think most people are never really in
that state like
you know this day and age especially
generation probably a generation younger
than the new and me
um like never just like sits and things
right or like like you know you look at
the tube like no one's just sat there
with their thoughts and if if they are
you're like what's wrong with that
person you know everyone's just like set
playing Candy Crush or you know
scrolling to tick tock or whatever it is
um
and and I'm you know I I don't but I'm
reading and like is that kind of the
same well there's obviously not as over
stimulating and I'm a huge fan of
reading but it's the same thing as your
podcast where it's like oh God you know
I need to cram in yeah you know I need
to finish this book this week or
whatever it is but yeah there is just
this kind of productivity porn
[Music]
um and yeah I think it's uh it's only
when you take all of that away that you
realize what's lost
okay so you got into Transcendental
Meditation pre silent Retreat yeah but
you were sort of on and off with it
knows it or that just stuck okay
completely and I've been doing it for
three no about four years now okay nice
and this was pre-bono experience
so this was around the time okay yeah
actually the burnout was like that I'm
not a kind of high stress Guy usually
but like I was stressed out that month I
was going through one of my short
two-month relationships something that
really ramps up the pressure for me and
so I was just like feeling stressed and
I was like I need to crack this and
that's what actually led me to trans led
to meditation
um so it was like those humans and then
uh learned that but then I was still you
know there's still the big nights like I
went on some
uh you know Lads golfing weekend ended
up being incredibly heavy and you know
it took me and one guy turned off we're
like great we've got you know alcohol
but
um you're collabing not doing any drugs
this weekend so I uh probably dab a
little bit too heavily in those back in
the day and then the third guy turned up
with just like every drug imaginable and
just had this very big night which ended
up taking assets at six in the morning
and I never taken acid before at that
point take some other psychedelics but
not acid and I just spent the next 16
hours just lying in bed staring at the
ceiling thinking to myself what the
he did with your life fan like what are
you doing and uh that was a big moment
that was about two weeks right I was
already booked to go on the Side
Elementary but that was about two weeks
before so by the time I got there I was
just like okay I am out of all of that
yeah crap and
yeah so it was a lot of things like
compounding and uh it did feel like a
bit of a Breaking Point
um which yeah I probably didn't admit at
the time but uh so yeah it was fine I'll
just get them but I really needed that I
needed needed that break
my building up for a decade really
so you went on the silent Retreat yes
what happened next what happened next so
it was yeah as I mentioned this Buddhist
temple on top of mountain it was
actually just outside Durham shallow
which is where the Dalai Lama live so I
went down to see him one of those not
not one-on-one there was a big event but
uh
the The Retreat itself again was half
but his philosophy of meditations as
well you know silent so about four hours
a day meditating in about four hours a
day Buddha's teaching but I think I went
into it
I would say uh just like very like naive
and skeptical of religion like very much
like you know obviously it's wrong quote
unquote and uh I think that was a real
eye-opener I I I I mean I wouldn't
particularly identify with the religion
now but I'd say I appreciate the role it
plays in society much more so the the
Buddhist philosophy the first four or
five days I was like yeah you know
interesting but not life changing and
then
halfway to The Retreat we got into the
Buddhist idea of attachment which is
like I need this to be happy and that
was just like
mind-blowing it explained all of the you
know things that had led me there and
all the things going on in my life at
the moment like one of the big questions
I was grappling with was like should I
go and try and do an MBA somewhere which
is a silly question hindsight and it was
just like and I spent the first four or
five days just like journaling on that
like the pros and cons and enjoying the
current place but like yeah that would
help me like step up a gear and then
I heard that and it was just like it
doesn't matter you know I didn't need it
either way you know
um and so so that was really
that was really empowering but that was
exactly what I needed to hear and then
towards the end of The Retreat the last
two days like intense meditation so you
spent like six or seven hours a day
meditating there's a lot of
visualization so like one of them for
example
is you spend 20 minutes focusing on your
breath and then 20 minutes
you have this guided meditation without
telling you to imagine yourself in the
ground so you're imagining yourself in
your grave and you're rotting and you
know worms are crawling in and out of
you and that that you you come out of
that just feeling like I don't think
I've ever felt so alive is when you come
out of that and you've just spent 20
minutes like properly meditating on your
on your death so so that was very
eye-opening and then there was a lot of
compassion stuff as well which I think
is super compassion is underrated like
if you can turn up with unconditional
compassion each day at work with your
family then that just kind of transcends
everything else you know if you like any
other crap if you can actually just
operate from a place of full compassion
which obviously is hard in practice is
in theory then you know everything else
is really you know just in detail so
that was I think that was the big thing
from that Retreat I've actually done
another one since which was different
some sort of a pass now which is like
eight or nine I was actually ten hours a
day meditating I did that earlier this
year
and that was a very intense experience
more about just like really so that's
where you're like focusing on the
sensations within yourself right and
like that Retreat really felt like work
but but this one this initial one I came
out of that just like buzzing just like
feeling so much joy and compassion
um and that that glow lasted for months
or even a year afterwards I I think you
know definitely some permanent changes
off the back of that like it changed my
perspective about a lot of things okay
like what well the I need this or that
to be happy was the big one
um
yeah I think it was just that kind of
apparently like I said up until that
point in my life I just had this like I
just wasn't comfortable in my own skin
and it was just this feeling of
um really caring what people think and
that just completely disappeared and you
know obviously it's come back to some
extent which is what we spoke about the
people pleasing earlier but I think it
was just like I can just go and do
whatever so I mean I got back from that
Retreat
um no intention to quit my job but then
so we were trying to raise a 10 million
pound funding rounds I had to come back
for a leadership meeting and two days
into that the money fell through we're
losing 300 000 a month and that night
we'd fired half a company closed the US
office close the Australian office I was
running marketing at the time running
growth and we paused all growth spent so
I just had a week twiddling my thumbs uh
and then had been thinking a lot about
like digital detoxing in my own phone
use had heard about this like cabin
movement and just sat there on a Friday
night and just thought what about that
cabin idea
um spent three hours Googling cabins and
was like this would probably work and I
quit on Monday and I think a lot of that
was just really feeling empowered of
like you can't just go and do anything
you know I had no idea how we were going
to do it but it was like yeah why not
you know why not go and give this a try
Okay question before we go into the
cabins thing um you said that one of the
big life-changing realizations was this
whole attachment thing
and people hear that all the time that I
oh just don't be attached to things and
like you know the idea of non-attachment
and like you know letting things go
there are even Disney songs about that
so what what was it about the experience
of doing it on a silent meditation
retreating the Himalayas in a Buddhist
temple that made you feel the truth of
that idea in a way that just hearing it
on a podcast might not have done it's a
great question
I mean I think you know you're putting
in the work there so you're going You're
meditating and you know you have hours
Nows now is to reflect on these things
right like it's a silent Retreat there's
nothing else you can do apart from
reflect on these things and I think you
need that you need to like
be present with yourself and like it's
building that self-awareness in yourself
so you can recognize it right because if
you just hear that you think oh yeah
smart idea but whatever but if you're
like really tuned into yourself then
when you hear that
it's like you you'll then kind of
coupling that up with how you're feeling
and what's been driving you the last few
days and oh my God that's exactly what
has been happening to me these last few
days when I've been like thinking about
this MBA or whatever it is and so into
that kind of
experience of really seeing it in
yourself like vividly in that moment and
you know that requires that being
offline and not being not thinking about
all these people who what's up to you it
requires really tuning in with yourself
am I actually figuring out what your own
experience is you know this is learning
by experience and you need the whole
Retreat and the meditation all that kind
of thing to intuitively know I think
where I was in my life I think people
could go to that Retreat and not come
away with that realization and maybe
Come Away with some different ones that
I didn't have so I think a lot of it was
like that was where I was in my life
where like that was causing me a lot of
you know grief and suffering
um and so the because interesting I did
this other Retreat earlier this year
much more intense experience and I think
I I I'll be honest I came out of that a
little disappointed a little shaken as
well there's a lot of meditating and
it's physically tough as well
um but I came out of that like a bit
disappointed because I had this sky-high
expectation because the Last Retreat I
did was so life-changing
um so I do think
where you are in life has a huge it's
like anything it's like what we read you
know what we listen to like
you as a person and where you are in
your life you could read one book and
not really do anything and then you
could read the same book in a year and
it yeah completely changed your life or
or you know likewise it's why giving
book recommendations is sometimes
difficult because it's like I've given
that but I'm assured in another's book
and then the person's like that I didn't
do anything for me so it's yeah it's
very uh dependent on the situation and
where you are
um but I think the what's interesting is
just exposing yourself to the right kind
of things you know so a Buddhist Retreat
is a place where you're quite likely to
have these realizations getting offline
out into nature reading books like these
are the kind of things where like
increasing the chances of that
Serendipity occurring if you're spending
10 hours a day scrolling through Tick
Tock you're probably not going to have
those realizations so it's about doing
the right things like you're not sure
where the um what's going to come out
when but it's kind of like what the
trauma we spoke about earlier yeah it's
like if you can do the right kind of
work then you know things will come up
and just be patient trust the process
and yeah do the work I guess hmm
yeah as you were as you were describing
that it sort of got me thinking around
how
you know just to to use like a just a
business example
you know taking a step back from the
day-to-day running of the business and
going on and off site with the team with
the leadership team and sort of mapping
out the strategy and listing down all
the issues and drawing the org chart and
like doing all the all the stuff
figuring out what's our annual goal and
things like that
and that's stuff that
you just don't have
time and space to do normally and it
requires an active concerted effort to
get quite Off the Grid like unplug from
the day-to-day running of the business
being in the business to think about
zooming out and working on the business
and then those contexts whenever we've
done that hey we've always just had like
loads of realizations that oh wow this
is the thing we should be doing but when
those days have been facilitated by a
coach they've been like some of the best
days of my life because it's just like
so thrilling and exhilarating actually
thinking about this stuff really
unpacking it and then the coaches says
one little thing one little thing like
what's the 20 of actions that are
driving 80 of the results and suddenly
it's like oh my God my mind is
blown but like obviously I know the
Predator print like obviously like you
know as I read it a zillion times over
it's like I'll speak what a 20 of inputs
like what's the 80 20 here it's like
yeah it's kind of like meaningless
but in in the context on and off site
with a flip chart and like load the
papers turn around we've spent the last
like 12 hours and or two days thinking
about this thing and unpacking
everything in the business that question
from an experienced person who has been
through the process before let's ask you
what are the 20 of things that are
driving multiple results you like
I understand and you feel it and then
you cut 80 of the things in business and
the business grows and then it's like
but you needed that time and space to
unpack in order to in order for that
realization to make sense and that was
the sort of image that came to mind as
you were describing that like
you need like you might have heard you
know just don't worry about things and
it's like what's that gonna do but if
you spent five days reflecting and
unpacking stuff you've got all the paper
all the papers out and now you're here
but if you just don't worry about it so
much oh yeah all of a sudden it's like I
get it 100 yeah I think that's it it's
like you know it's getting to the truth
of the situation you know like the work
is understanding What's Really Gonna
going on here like once you get to that
place then what you should do is like
straightforward but that's the hard
place to get to you know like to see the
forest for the trees right we spend all
of our days just like in the weeds and
it's taking the time zooming out both
both for a company and ourselves right I
do think yeah obviously you compare the
two and they are they are comparable you
know it's the same it's the same stuff
like we're all running our own little
companies uh each day and executive it's
uh it's really understanding like what's
actually going on and that is much
deeper than we think like we have no
idea really what's happening in this
most of the time we know so little about
the human body we're learning about it
we knowing less about the mind
um but you know you can you can kind of
just tune into your experience and
and the more you understand what's
actually going on if like if you really
knew let's let's say someone
has some you know very disturbing trauma
and it shows up as just anger their
whole life it's until they know that
this trauma caused that um
then you know it's not obvious what the
path forward is right it's just like I'm
an angry person you know shows up again
and again and again and again and it's
really not obvious it's like how would
you know what to do but then if suddenly
one day they find out that actually it's
linked to this one thing that happened
to them when they're a teenager then
something is obvious it's like all right
well I need to cure that thing and then
the problem will go away so it's really
about spending the time like you know
ideas are cheap wisdom is or yeah
there's a great phrase beware of wisdom
not earned I think that's so applicable
because like you know you you can
all of the wisdom is is there all of the
wisdom other people's wisdom is there
for us to to do it but
what to implement and where to improve
and how to implement that requires us to
to really understand ourselves or
uncomfortably
[Music]
um
yeah that's really nice
that also reminds me of something I've
been been thinking about recently which
when it comes to just someone
intentionally reading some people will
say like oh books are pointless because
you can just read a summary or you can
just watch a video or off this could
have been a blog post
but a blog post that summarizes the top
10 insights from I don't know Atomic
habits or you know from Siddhartha or
from the well like whatever spiritual
text you want it's not it's not going to
do anything that's unknown to wisdom and
you kind of need
even just in Reading you need the fluff
you need the stories the stuff that
doesn't actually seemingly add a value
to the main pithy highlightable
tweetable takeaway
yeah you need it to understand the the
takeaway
and if you don't have that you just get
a list of a list of pithy quotes that
like sound nice on the surface you're
like yeah and you just don't take any
action on them 100 I think I think
biographies are a great example of that
because you can learn so much by reading
about you know people who have gone on
to do impactful things or whatever and
you know it's if you read a long
biography it might take I don't know 15
20 hours and it's that time you're
spending sitting with that person and
really understanding them through every
situation yeah and you know just
building the idea of that character in
the mind and then you know as you say
you really understand why they have done
something you have the context around it
but you are also spending that time like
your mind is working all the time you're
reading your mind is kind of pondering
in the background Like Making
Connections Etc yeah and so like that is
the time where you're earning what you
then take away from the book and so I
think yeah this we have this um
attitude of just like instant instant
results you know yeah and of course you
need to put in the time and so I think
the process of reading a book
is uh you know it's super valuable it
really helps kind of begin just develop
concentration and yeah that I I started
reading a lot about three or four years
ago I didn't read that much before that
and you know concentrations massively
improved and like the amount I can read
has massively improved and I think that
is a
great muscle to build because again it
just calms you down makes you more
present and just allows you to think
deeper about things
yeah
yeah I realized I was about I was about
to make that mistake this morning where
I was listening I was listening to this
online course and it was like it's like
50 hours of training from this guy who's
literally sort of playing the same game
as I am but just like two levels above
and it's like yeah I have 50 hours of
training like could I just put it
through like a you know I was thinking
I'll download the MP3 put it through
chat GPT get the transcription another
summary I was like I'll take the actual
points away
that's just a dumb way thinking about it
it's like there's literally this guy
who's like open source does knowledge
it's literally roughly where I want to
be
like why wouldn't I listen to him for 50
hours and take notes and really think
about it and do the work to earn the
wisdom rather than just
read a summary of the transcript and
action and the highlightable action
points yeah because the other quote that
comes to mind is uh you are the sub of
The Five People You spend the most time
with you also do some of the content you
consume right and when you are when
you're listening to a content creator
for 50 hours and you're spending 50
hours with that person yeah and so yeah
it's it's all the little things that
kind of trickle out of that that uh
where the value is you know as you say
not the not the one liner not the
one-liner yeah and sometimes the
one-liner is the one lighter but but but
it's a one-liner of like oh
yeah everything's Downstream of lead
generation that one liner makes a
perfect sense when you have context is
that until you have contact exactly okay
cool what's next
um so cabins cabins so you said you got
back from the side of the tree quit the
job and you were thinking about cabins
yeah so I I I've been thinking a lot
about like digital detoxing read a great
book called um digital minimalism by Cal
Newport earlier that year interestingly
I uh he talks a lot about unplugged and
unplugging and I was like oh I'm plugged
to be a great name for business before I
was thinking about cabins so tried to
buy unplugged.com just in case I have a
set of business costs like 100 Grand so
I didn't buy it one day one day yeah and
uh so that had been on my mind and then
obviously went to the silent Retreat
which which further reinforced it
um and had heard about this like cabin
movement and I think father Kevin so
there's like a kind of tiny house
movement and you know there's lots of
like cabin Concepts in other countries
and what's interesting about cabins is
they have let's call it tax appeal you
know especially in this like Instagram
world we live in you know it's sexy it's
aspirational and I think digital
detoxing even the phrase it sounds a bit
Fabby so when we were sitting down we
can talk a bit about the business in a
second but when we were sitting down uh
to create unplugged
we've made a list of phrases we weren't
going to use and one of those digital
detox because it like sounds a bit fatty
yeah and then after a while we're like
well actually this kind of is the thing
yeah I'm gonna say the work on the
website
yeah yeah so it's like rather than
worrying too much about it why don't we
just try and make it cool you know and I
think to affect change in this day and
age I kind of say with Tesla and
electric cars but you have to make it
sexy and so I think that's what that's
what we thought cabins could bring to
the space so the concept behind
unplugged we put cabins an hour or two
from City Life people
go for three days literally lock their
phone in the Box we give them a marker
to knock here and leave them to it so
it's really what we are as effective an
experienced company where we want people
to experience three nights offline in a
cabin in nature
and what sort of effect does this have
so I didn't I didn't know for context I
did one of these last year and didn't
actually take it seriously because like
and and this is one of the areas where I
think my people pleasing Tendencies came
up because as as I was doing the OM
like a couple minutes ago I was thinking
you know it would be cool to do a proper
unplugged kind of Cabin in the Woods
retreat thing why didn't I do it last
time oh last time it's because
you know my there was something
happening at home and something
happening with friends and like
something happening with my girlfriend
where I was like uh you know I don't
really I can almost do the cabin another
time it's like it doesn't need to be
this weekend it's like my grandma's
visiting this weekend and it's like oh I
should just you know and then my brother
was like hey you can do the unplug thing
anytime like you know the guy's like
come on it's like I was like okay fine
like why not it's like oh the team one
could film a video as well what yeah I
might as well film it while I'm there
and it's like all of a sudden this thing
just becomes another work thing that I
sort of went to the cabin
I drove there I was 20 minutes away from
home drove back home because we had
people coming over I drove back to the
cabin sleep overnight drove back in the
minute there's just so it sort of just
became a bit of a hotel room yeah and
completely defeated the purpose of
actually doing an unplugged type
situation but that situation came to
mind where I was like
I really wanted to do this but I
overrode my own preferences for the sake
of the perceived preferences of other
people which in the moment might have
been the right thing to do because like
my grandmother but like yeah of that
situation played out over over time I
think gets us to a place where yeah yeah
I don't value my own preferences enough
possibly yeah well so I think what
happens when you do it so what doesn't
happen is you don't change your habits
right you don't come back and you never
check your phone again you know don't
change your habits in three days but
what does happen is you change your
perception so for most of us
probably in the last decade we have not
spent a day
even or definitely not three days off
our phones and so you don't we don't see
what we're missing so when you go and do
this again lock your phone away
the there's something very empowering
just about that moment of actually just
locking in about something oh my God
okay I'm actually just unreachable from
those three days that's that's kind of
cool and then the the first AI is a
little bit anxious because you know you
kind of feel like you've lost limb but
then you just get this like deep sense
of calm and again that is how we are
built to operate and
experiencing that is incredibly powerful
so you know we get what's really
interesting is it feels like it starts
people off on that Journey right so they
come and stay with us and experience
this and then
spending that time offline then makes
you crave that more
and so then seeking it out more in your
life but not only do you kind of the
changeable section on that but you also
get all the benefits of the kind of deep
sense of calm and relaxation and
honestly you just come back to better
person like we used to check people in
uh ourselves at the start we were
cleaning up the cabins ourselves and the
difference between people when they
checked in and checked out was crazy
they looked 10 years younger which is
insane in three days and so I think
again it's it's a lot of not knowing
just just how much you're carrying until
you actually just go and spend that time
offline
and so it's really about starting people
off on that Journey you know because at
the moment the momentum is in the
direction of spending more time online
you know and so our goal is start to
move that momentum in another Direction
so we have you know many people now who
come and do this you know every six to
12 months I think that is really the
goal like how can we normalize this and
make it something people just do let you
go to the gym for your physical health
you go and do a digital detox yeah once
every three to six months as part of
your mental health
singing the Praises of this to her
friends when I first heard about the
concept and when we first met like the
year 18 months ago everyone was like oh
I mean what but I could just do that at
home or I could just do that in an
Airbnb why am I going to a slightly
bougie cabin in the winter for the sake
of just not being on my phone
for sure so the the key is could but
they don't right so like this is all
about actually getting people to
experience it you know and the cabin is
great for that because it's sexy because
it you know it's very tangible you know
it feels like the whole experience it's
something you can tell your family you
can tell work like I am going to spend
three nights offline at this cabin it's
this whole thing and that is what
empowers you to do it yeah and then you
know our job is to then actually have
everything there so you don't need to
check your photos there's a Polaroid
there's a map there's a Nokia and so
really what we are doing is giving you
that time offline in nature you know and
that is the key and then once we've
achieved that then yeah the nature and
being offline and you yourself do the
work like just being there
it's you know you can go and spend three
nights online you don't really have to
do whatever you want but you will
destimulate you'll feel this deep sense
of calm so yeah our goal is really to
get you out there get you offline and
then just let you let your body let your
mind calm down and let nature take its
course and so what sort of what what
sort of stuff do people say after a
three night thing so like you know we've
gifted this to everyone in our team and
I think like half the team has done it
so far and everyone's got away from it
being like Oh my God that was so sick
what's all the stuff do you hear from
people yeah for sure so I think the
like the biggest Insight is just like oh
my God why why am I so busy right like
because I think everyone goes into it
thinking like the world's gonna end if
they spend three days offline and the
big Insight is that oh you actually can
just go and do this you know which is
crazy so I think people you know really
feel that sense of
um just just like perspective on their
life of like like why was I so busy and
so crazy like whenever I do this I go in
I'm like uh oh my God like I just need
to do Less meat tips why am I trying to
cram in all these meetings so I think it
really
helps you give you the tools to go back
into your life and
just like we'll know what we should be
doing more of but like people come out
of this with like uh oh I should pick up
exercise again or I should start eating
healthier again or like whatever it is
so I think it's that you know that rest
as you say as we were talking about
earlier kind of cures that low-key
burnout it just gets people back in this
back in the driving seat you know so
like it just what we see is not only the
experience has its benefits but then
afterwards you know it's what you take
back into your life uh and yeah what we
hear is that a lot of people go back and
they will Implement if they're a couple
they'll go and like start doing a day a
week whether they go to a restaurant
leave their phones at home or that kind
of thing so yeah I think that is the
that's the nicest thing to see is just
like starting people off on that Journey
yeah nice
final question like for how how does the
business side of this work like what
does it like if someone was like you
know what I want to start a business
where I put cabins in woods and get
people and get like Tech Bros from in my
city to go there for three days like
what what is involved in running a
business like this for sure so simple in
theory uh not so in practice but yeah
basically we own and operate the cabins
so we work with the company to get them
built and then we work with landowners
on a revenue share so
Farms of the stage classically again
there's a big move for Farm
diversification there also is just a
beautiful
um you know the English Countryside is
beautiful so that there's a lot of
beautiful spots out there
so for us we're really about just
getting our cabins in these areas and
then obviously building a building a
brand and really selling people in
London
ironically on social media yeah
um about why they should come and do
this and then just getting people to
experience it so
civil business cabins up and then fill
them we have 17 cabins now we'll be at
32 by the end of this year starting to
spread out across the UK and uh yeah
it's just amazing see all the
interesting ways people are doing it as
you mentioned with your team like we
have a lot of companies who use this and
employee benefit we have lots of people
like you know gifting it or making it a
regular thing yeah it's a nice gift to
give to someone yeah exactly exactly so
I give you the gift
time of flying how much does it cost to
build a cabin it's about 45 000 so
they're expensive okay but then so if
you have a garden you can just build a
get a cabin built in your garden for 45k
yeah because these cabinets are quite
nice got like with the toilet and the
stove and everything yeah exactly
exactly so so that's all in yeah you can
uh I think that's it I think it's as
well it's like
you know a lot of people would like to
go and spend time in a cabin in the
countryside yeah that's a cool thing
yeah but haven't got 45k lying around so
anyway to put all of these things does
that make it more accessible like in
countries like
um Sweden you know Scandinavia they have
this culture of Summer houses yeah
that's what they call some houses which
are these effectively cabins that
everyone has and it's just the nice
thing to go and do and I think
especially in London like you know we
have millions and millions of people who
just spent all of their time in London
they really have the option to go out I
think as you post covered people are
starting to discover the British
Countryside more and like actually you
know you can do some pretty amazing
things just an hour or two from London
so I think you know we also want to
bridge that Gap it's like how do you
have all these people who are burnt out
and stressed out in the city and how do
we get them offline into nature outside
of the city and cabins are a great way
of doing that
um so we're gonna scale up that I think
business is a lot about focus and doing
one thing really well and then in the
future there might be a wider unplugging
digital detox spray so we will see but
so starting times nice and so for
someone so we'll put links in the show
notes video description if anyone wants
to do this uh mostly they're in and
around London so we have a fairly
International reach so probably not
relevant for other people but
um for someone listening to this he's
gotten this far he's like I love the
idea of switching off and going to a
cabin or something for a few days and or
taking my phone what would be your
step-by-step guide if let's say they're
based in I don't know somewhere other
than England where these cabins are not
a thing yeah for sure so he you really
want to remove all the reasons you would
all the excuses you would have for
checking your phone because that that's
what it'll be it'll be like you go with
the best intentions and there's like oh
yeah but I just need to check like the
weather or I just need to check get the
map or whatever it is so if
if you want to go and stay in an Airbnb
or whatever it is and leave your phone
behind then
you know get a map of the local area in
in the UK especially you can just get an
OS map of an area
um and that means you can leave your
phone behind you know get a watch get an
alarm clock like whatever it is you need
but what I would also say is just start
small you know you don't need to go and
spend three nights in the countryside
just put your phone in the drawer just
go for a walk just don't take your phone
to the shop for example yeah so I think
we one we you know we try and over
complicate it and then we beat ourselves
up when we we do check our phone right
like you know we all kind of you know
obviously phones are great and we like
our phones but we also kind of hate our
phones you know like it does bring a lot
of stress into our lives yeah so I think
we then kick ourselves you know that we
spend so much time on it but when I
mention what I do to people that oh my
God I'm terrible on my phone I could
never do that or I really need that or
whatever it is and then there's just
this narrative that was Shackled to our
phone and there's nothing we can do just
just start small you know just put your
phone in a drawer just leave it out of
the bedroom at night take half an hour
an hour in the morning
um and just just keep just keep plugging
away and you know if and when you're
ready to come to a cabin then you know
to find us fantastic yeah actually it's
been wonderful thank you so much Ali
great sir great to be here
all right so that's it for this week's
episode of Deep dive thank you so much
for watching or listening all the links
and resources that we mentioned in the
podcast are going to be linked down in
the video description or in the show
notes depending on where you're watching
or listening to this if you're listening
to this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye